tous
[Musique]
face à la première
bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux face à
la première l'émission politique de la
première sous deux formats en direct la
sur nos réseaux sociaux le vendredi 16
heures et diffusions radio le dimanche à
midi bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour
entendre un homme politique qui a
beaucoup à dire on l'a vu par exemple
très offensif notamment lors de la
présentation de ses voeux aux membres de
son parti politique bonjour serge
letchimy bonjour et bon jouant toute la
martinique
député président du parti progressiste
martiniquais chef de file d'ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle merci
d'être avec nous pour vous interroger
d'en face à la première avec nous alain
livory de la rédaction télé de
martinique à première bonjour alain
bonjour maurice bonjour monsieur le
député les sujets sont nombreux
la campagne électorale qui a débuté pour
les européens au mois de mai pour les
municipales de l'année prochaine et
pauvres la septième en 2021
le ppm qui a désigné très clairement ses
ennemis ceux de la martinique et la
majorité à la 7ème et l'état nous y
reviendrons serge chimie les
personnalités qui quittent leur siège de
maire rodolphe désiré par exemple aux
marins pierre symbole lamentin des
applaudissements pour leur parcours mène
par te t-il pas trop tard et puis un
nouveau venu sur la scène politique est
payant n'en parla également
et puis à ces dossiers qui agacent
l'abattement fiscal autre pont sans
supprimer par emmanuel macron la
molécule chlordécone et l'indemnisation
des victimes pas que les agriculteurs et
puis la contestation sociale contre trop
d'impôts contre la vie qui est arrivé
contre la vie chère qui est arrivé en
france après nos pays on s'en souvient
il ya dix ans voici les thèmes retenus
pour face à la première alain livory
première question comme un parfum de
campagne qui a déjà débuté tout à fait
maurice alors rebonjour serge letchimy
tout près il ya les municipales de
basse-pointe vous êtes allé soutenir
marie thérèse casimir husky et maire
sortante c'est la bonne personne au bon
poste pour vous bonjour monsieur d'evry
merci de me recevoir
ici on s'aidera du min est ce que c'est
la bonne version avait été élu maire de
besoin donc il ya une légitimité
démocratique qui s'est exprimée ce qui
se passe là vous lui c'est un coup le
mandat il ya une déposition que je ne
commente pas
quais et des démissions qui conduise à
une loi d'élections est ce que c'est une
stratégie un petit peu anti démocratique
pour mettre fin à son mandat
un coût de vie de débauche ce n'est pas
parce que son musical ou est ce que
c'est ça serait ridicule et c'est
pourquoi vous avez quelqu'un qui était
lui qui n'a pas détourné de fonds qui
fait un très très bon corée sous le
terrain et il suffit d'une démission à
la fois de ceux qui protestent pour des
raisons précises et cueilli un
accompagnement de démission par d'autres
jeux qui sont des opposants pour
l'objectif c'est le provoquer des
élections je trouve pas ça très correct
est très démocratique
mais c'est une réalité pour répondre à
la question très rapidement et
précisément oui c'est la bonne personne
elle est excellente dans son travail et
je crois que dans une mairie il faut de
la rigueur il faut pas laisser passer
des choses pense
il faut aussi de la souplesse des
missions dans son propre camp est-ce
qu'il ya pas un problème que m'a dit
thérèse qu'un si grand jeu quand
j'entends qu'on veut quand ont
démissionné en commente le fait qu' on
est accusé quelqu'un de vrai accusés
soupçonnés et peut-être à cause de
quelqu'un demain matin d'avoir par
exemple commander un téléphone portable
et d'en avoir lusage pas pour lui mais
pour quelqu'un d'autre que quelle mère
qui peut accepter ça dans kent
à mon avis si ça s'avère très juste elle
a raison de prendre des sanctions
et derrière ça il est protestation je ne
comprends pas la seule chose c'est que
marie thérèse quasiment youth a permis
au grand nord de se désenclaver d'être
connue a permis à bath peine de
commencer à exister à nouveau et à
permis justement sa commune de pouvoir
avant de l'espérance de l'espoir avec
des équipements des manifestations
autour du nautisme moto de la
restauration du pas du sien du sur
l'église tout cas quelle est
véritablement dans une très bonne
dynamique il faut l'a soutenu c'est ce
que nous faisons
les voeux du ppm c'est à la fin du mois
de janvier serge letchimy on vous a vu
combatif agressif peut-être le ppm et
dans son processus actuellement
de désignation de ses candidats avec un
ennemi tout des signes et legrand semble
est pour bat payant chance parents amis
et alliés personnes de ces gens là ne
trouve grâce à vos yeux manifestement si
on vous a bien entendu au siège de
traînel à la fin du mois de janvier est
très simple et pas polémiste je
considérais que lorsqu'on fait une offre
à la population seront présentes à une
équipe il faut absolument avoir un
minimum de valeurs à défaut ni des tic
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2015 on a
décidé de rassembler tout le monde
vous savez ça a touché positivement
certaines personnes ou 10 ans en mettant
les uns des pays nantis des gens de
droite des modérés des communes
nouvelles offres politiques
voilà c'est ça les gens sont intéressés
à ça et j'avais clairement dit ce genre
de melting-pot ne pas d être
désobligeant
ça va pas marcher parce que gérer une
telle collectivité
il faut au moins se respecte et sous ses
lignes politiques
voilà on a en a la conséquence trois ans
après le pays est planté le pays et
arrêté
il n'y a absolument rien de fait de
concret et ça ne fonctionne pas tout le
monde le dit y compris des journalistes
aient compris l'état ouais y compris
l'état j'entends souvent l'état le 10 le
pays qui est le plus en retard comme
facile à dire ça que les journalistes
issa que l'état dit ça c'est pas nous
sommes que j'entends et peut-être que
vous le dites pas à pas par dire
ontologique mais beaucoup de
journalistes qui s'exprime par ailleurs
de manière personnelle
alice clairement que ça va pas mon pays
et aujourd'hui vous avez la martinique
qui est considéré comme le dernier
département d'outre-mer matière de
développement économiques en matière
d'investissements en matière de
croissance en matière de taux de chômage
on a une réalité qui est excellent ajout
données chif lorsque j étais à la région
madame année au département on avait six
servions 300 millions d'euros à peu près
là on l'investît que 120 millions de qui
manque pratiquement 180 millions d'euros
quand vous avez moins 180 millions
d'euros de fonds publics qui attire près
de 700 millions d'euros total de fonds
d'investissement vous avez pratiquement
un manque de l'ordre de 500 millions
d'euros pas an d'investissements dans le
pays
il faut pas se leurrer il faut pas être
surpris de savoir que les gens partent
loupé en guyane pour investir donc c'est
un pays qui est à l'arrêt c'est la
conséquence en plus de la situation
politique et ses cieux ou tôt
aujourd'hui un constat navrant que ce
cette collectivité
avec cette alliance ont plus personne ne
se parle plus personne ne se parle à la
messe qui forment leur mouvement ah non
il y en a même un qui a la forme et son
mouvement voulait se dire mais bon mais
et en plus qui il reste chef de file de
la majorité en place ce qui est
véritablement assez incroyable pour vous
plus il faut qu ils démystifient
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils fassent
jeunes enfants qu'ils ont besoin de gens
qui je parle avec respect est vraiment
et monsieur ni loi faut-il envers ce
chenil à à créer son mouvement et j'ai
regardé ça avec beaucoup d'objectivité
et même en faisant des commentaires
positifs parce que vous avez pas été
tendre avec les lors de l'achat des jeux
termine et monsieur et jeunes ados qui
est qui sont son partenaire de son
président oui a aussi mon respect il n'y
a pas de problème là dessus la seule
chose quand vous créiez un mouvement
parce que vous vous opposez à celui que
vous considérez comme un dictateur comme
quelques des frais comptables etc et que
cette personne est à la tête d'une
institution
vous êtes le patron de la majorité de
cette personne d'annie du président que
la collectivité et vous restez vous
démissionnez évoqué votre parti contre
lui est pour quelque chose
vous manifestez sa part des idées et des
axes de politique de développement je ne
vois rien il faut que les verres sales
fois de ma vie j'ai jamais dit de
renverser je dis simplement d'avoir
l'honnêteté et surtout le courage de
créer à l'intérieur de la ctm un
mouvement d'opposition à l'intention de
le faire il a dit hier
certes j'ai rien vu il est majeur mais
selon vous il y il y est allé pas
suffisamment franco pour vous je sais
pas de commentaires trop à faire là
dessus parce que vous savez les
scissions vin est parti ça existe mais
la seule chose je pense ça c'est bon
point de vue personnes qu'il a attendu
longtemps et que ce qu'est la critique
dit quoi eh bien écoutez et si rien ne
change que c'est quand même lui qui a
adoubé monsieur martin pendant des
années il découvre que cet indicateur
est que c'est quelqu'un de fréquentable
c'est son droit mais se change sur le
champ ce que nous disons d'ailleurs
depuis très longtemps
vous n'avez pas été tendre je reviens
dessus avec jean philippe miller lors de
la création de son mouvement
je reprends un beau mot une dynamique
creuse évident sur son désir pour tunis
pour vous l'avais dit à la tribune
bpm d'accord très bien vous avez rajouté
le mont port tunis mais sinon je répète
dynamique
kruse et opportuniste parce qu'il n'ya
pas d'idée il n'y a pas de projet et
surtout et c'est comme seul projet danse
oui contre ce projet beppo mettre en
place son projet c'est simplement par
opposition à une structure qui l'a
accompagnée et dynamiser pendant très
longtemps c'est pas pendant deux jours
pendant des années c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est creux alors ça conduit à
quelque chose qui me semble assez vite
politiquement et aucun projet séduit
pour lutter contre la dépendance
qu'est ce que ça signifie lutter contre
la dépendance s'il est pour l'autonomie
alors parce que le lutter contre la
dépendance et assumer plus de
responsabilités locales donc signer pour
l'autonomie qu'il dise très clairement
milite pour le rapprochement des deux
courants non je pense qu'il a fait son
choix et vous n'avez pas travaillé avec
sur philippe meylan écoutez je n'ai
jamais refusé avec et que ce soit
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée nationale il
nous arrive de travailler à la base
comme je travaille à l'offre politique
comme je trouvais avec beaucoup de
parlementaires qui veulent bien échanger
discuter je pense à mathiasin je tombe
pense à d'autres qui nous avons mené des
batailles ensemble il n'y a pas de
position et systématique il ya
simplement la volonté de dire nous ne
faisons pas de rapprochement simplement
d'opportunités la pros
la présence de jenny dulys à la création
de ce mouvement de pays à ce n'est pas
un coup de canif à plm
non pas du tout vous savez à la fois
génie lui ses pieds robotique
ce sont deux personnes d'une grande
courtoisie d'ailleurs je cite il y avait
d'autres personnes étaient là comme
christiane mariette que je connais très
bien qui est quand même du bbm que
camille chauvet je crois au point d'un
exemple étaient présents donc il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ont répondu à
l'invitation
tant mieux c'est une question de respect
mais c'est pas parce qu'on a répondu à
l'invitation qu'on est dans l'adhésion
serge letchimy deux hommes politiques
ont décidé de quitter leur fauteuil de
maire on va les cités pierre samot du
lamentin et rodolphe désiré omar un peu
plus de 80 ans pour les deux il était
temps pour eux de tourner la page
ce sont des décisions qui sont
difficiles pour les hommes et femmes qui
ont occupé pendant très longtemps et qui
ont vraiment marqué leur commune parce
que pierre samot a vraiment marqué la
commune du lamentin vraiment et cas
positivement en plus donc c'est
compliqué on est on est on sait pas
c'est pas seulement envie de rester
ce sont les autres qui vous disent mais
non par pas tout de suite et ces croix
de pierre dussault posé plusieurs fois
la question est ce que je me présente ou
pas qu'il a eu ce courage et la propreté
de son départ parce que il y avait
beaucoup de départs dans le camp dans
les histoires d opposition et ça s'est
très bien passé parce que il a à la fois
pris une décision de manière anticipée
parce que c'est parfait demanda et
deuxièmement il a aussi présenté un
homme mais qui a des qualités
exceptionnelles
c'est un vrai homme de combat de lutte
politique il a des positions très
claires et david zodiac et qui sont son
premier joint depuis depuis un moment
et quant à rodolphe désiré je vais je
dirais la même chose mais je dis que
plus c'est le pearl beaucoup de choses
c'est enfin un des pères de la nation
martiniquaise dans tous les combats
qu'il a menés politique je résume ça
comme ça par cette phrase je pense que
personne ne conteste sa était en prison
pour la cause martiniquaise ses talents
prison ferme à lausanne où il à faire de
l'eau jammes
il s'est battu beaucoup deuxièmement
honnêtement désiré et le père de
l'économie bleus
c'est à dire celui qui nous a éduqués à
à nous réconcilier avec la mer parce que
vous savez il ya un paradoxe écologique
on est pas on est on est en difficulté
dans la relation avec la mer pour
plusieurs raisons la sauvage à vivre les
batteries cache pas qu'on en parlera
tout à l'heure ce point de vue là et
désiré a fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
c'est vraiment le progrès 6 c'est
vraiment l'expression du travail des
élus ppm des élus progressistes c'est à
dire ils ont pourrais projet c'est pas
ce ne sont pas des gens qui viennent aux
élections sans projet et désiré loulo
coudol aimé césaire pour prendre ces
trois exemples là ce sont des élus
progressistes qui a qui sont arrivés
dans cette commune la danse et communes
là avec un projet qui ont exécuté leurs
projets comme word et c'est plus ça bien
évolué ceinture quand vous regardez
désirer eh bien il a vraiment donné une
dimension nautique en matière de
plaisance à la commune du marais c'est
irréversible c'est exceptionnel et c'est
exactement le même profil que marie
thérèse quasi marius havas moins deux
époux est ce que vous pensez déjà votre
départ est ce que vous pensez à votre
succession d'en parler parce qu'avec ne
serait-ce que la prépa la préparation de
la succession et d'eurasie côtes de
l'état de quelque chose j'ai été douze
ans directeur général de la sema ouais
j'ai passé la main j'ai été une dizaine
d'années conseil général
disposant maire de fort de france j'ai
passé voilà donc soit plus près serait
socialement les conçoit plus saillants
celle des tripes vous êtes vous êtes
député en exercice le président du ppm
est-ce que vous avez été président de la
région martinique est ce que vous direz
dans les prochains mois voici la
personne que je verrai par exemple pour
donner la liste pour la septième en 2021
non pas comme ça passe quelque chose
concertée il faut discuter avec à la
fois dans le parti mais aussi occupé
même parce que nous avons une alliance
qui n'est pas un parti mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose d'improbable ce n'est
vraiment pas quelque chose d'improbable
nous allons discuter
je pense que il faut avoir vraiment
beaucoup de force pour nous déterminer
si on note aujourd'hui quel état
d'esprit vous dire quel état d'esprit
êtes vous avez envie d'y aller j'ai
clairement indiqué que j'avais fait une
offre à la population martiniquaise en
2015 avec un vrai projet la population
une majorité de la production a décidé
ne pas faire ce choix se choisir ceux de
groupes hétéroclites et combler ainsi et
ce choix je respecte mais j'avais décidé
de donner 50 ma vie encore à partir de
c'est une décision qui était dans ma
tête qui est extrêmement clair parce que
cinq ans à la tête de la ctm aurions
fait c'est beaucoup de travail ou ou à
l'envers parce que je veux pas je dis
blanc quand c'est pas moi je ne
travaille pas comme toi et comme j'aime
travailler ses 9 heures du matin 1h du
matin tous les jours tous les jours donc
avec une responsabilité extrêmement
lourde
un pays qu'il faut redresser qu'il faut
vraiment propulsé cette offre était là
mais ce choix n'a pas été fait en me
demande comment c'est encore cinq ans
bon franchement j'ai quand même des
enfants et j'ai une organisation la fed
le mois de janvier en action que non je
seulement vous devez comprendre des
coins je ne peux pas prendre de décision
mais il faut vraiment réfléchir c'est
d'abord le choix de vie parce que si je
décide de donner cinq ans de ma vie à la
population martiniquaise pour m'aider
est cinq à dix ans on peut pas finir
comme ça parce que ouais moi levi au
pouvoir je veux c'est cela je suis
parlementaire
je fais mon travail alors pour répondre
à votre question pour quelle raison vous
avez dix à cinquante mille points
excusez moi que j'étais offensif
lors la rentrée politique du parti
progressiste martiniquais mais il faut
bien comprendre les raisons quand vous
avez un pays qui est dans l'état actuel
et quand vous avez une situation de
violence que nous avons dans ce pays là
quand vous avez la démonstration que ce
genre d'alliance là que certes on peut
appeler un alias manger cochon ça ne
marche pas et que votre pays est
discrédité par tous quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui ne dialogue même pas avec
les syndicats qui violent de ses
salariés soit des dizaines de personnes
sont en burn out à la collectivité
territoriale pas des investissements
qu'on les paie pour le pays
les associations qui tirent la langue
qu'ils sont en train de mourir des cd
des gens qui défilent dans ma permanence
vous demander du travail à manger à
boire 6 3 1 ça se passe où il s'agirait
de marie-jeanne disait à l'époque où
vous étiez sauf si vous vous n'êtes pas
au port le banc le jeune vous êtes
maintenant d'écouter j'ai maintenant
c'est quand même voulu dire s'il était
question elle est partie de vous le dire
parce que il n'ya il n'ya est ce que
vous voulez ce qu'il faut hurler avec
les loups
quand on est en plein tumulte on
appelait en plein tumulte ampleur quand
éboué quand tout ne va pas est-ce qu'il
faut hurler avec les loups bien prendre
de la hauteur et murmurer mais on prend
de la hauteur
c'est ce qu'on fait mais bien sûr c'est
pas parce qu'on parle avec fermeté
comprend pas de la hauteur et pour quand
on critique est très clairement quelque
chose c'est pas pour ça que vous êtes
dans le canton dans l'histoire vous êtes
de a de manière ferme de dire clairement
que ça va pas et donc et pour moi nous
sommes une opposition structurée avec
jean claude duverger et nous sommes une
opposition politique d'ailleurs la seule
qui a fait applaudir puisqu'avec cette
espèce d'alliance du communiste est à
dire pas du pôle nord au pôle sud
il n'y a plus d'opposition aujourd'hui
grèce' à la droite
daianu plaisir à vous taquinez non non
non je suis très solide derrière mon
plaisir est de l'opposition de du
président dit m vous avez vu ça vous il
a essayé de manifester parce qu'on la
subit jamais insulté quoi il a essayé de
bouger et ils entrent en baver la wii
très rapidement parce qu'il nous reste
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder sur
l'aspect politique purement politique
politicienne et toujours à propos du du
marais qui est le relais du ppm dans
cette commune à partir du monde de
plaisir les avoir reçus ce qui est très
clair qui était entré en jeu il ya un
communiqué de presse qui est arrivé chez
vous pour vous dire que ça y est on a
mis en place le comité d'investiture
nous donnerons balisiers de pouvoir
s'exprimer cela c'est la période là où
on est en plein période dorée absolument
les je ne peux pas en ce cas là ne rien
vous dire puisqu'il n'y a pas de choix
fait par le président du ppm ou par qui
que ce soit c'est un choix qui est fait
par le comité national après un vote à
bulletin secret les airs mais le
candidat que vous allez soutenir que le
pic historique qui lie à aux marins
beaucoup de personnalités et puis à 7 en
manque de quelques personnalités qui
vont émerger la discussion se fera à
fond on va trouver sotra aussi avec
yvonne fritz
je vous ai dit qu'il ya beaucoup de
possibilités à la fois aux marais y
compris à fort de france y compris à
bellefontaine r oui on analysera la
situation justement ce que vous avez
nommés de trois communes parlons de
celle de ducos est-ce que là aussi
louis marie sainte aura votre soutien
comment ça va se passer
est-ce que vous allez vous attendez le
soutien du maire clé du jeu las je viens
vous dire que le seul un processus de
désignation n'est même pas là tout peut
encore quand on peut aimer la vie est
tellement candidats ça fait déjà 20
minutes qu'on parle de la politique on
parler de l'actualité sociale à serge
letchimy avec un week-end de
commémorations à chalvet 1974 il ment
tragiques qui ont secoué cette partie du
nord du pays mais pas que sur des
revendications salariales nous sommes en
la france c'est j les jeunes qui
protestent contre une sur fiscalité
contre la vie chère contre tout ce qui
grève le pouvoir d'achat l'actualité
sociale est très chargé with you the
tiny alors comment vous voyez est ce que
c'est un éternel recommencement comment
vous voyez cette contestation des gilets
jaunes qui n'en finit pas de d'asphyxier
le pouvoir en place il ya deux aspects
pour moi rien un aspect extrêmement
légitimes de ces manifestations contre
l'inégalité d'ailleurs j'ai dénoncé ça
il n'y a pas très longtemps ovationné et
en même temps sur qu'on appelle le
pouvoir d'achat en gros on a une
situation est grave ou des russes le pc
ou mac rôle de ce point de vue c'est
tromper qu'il y a simplement qu un seul
axe de croissance et de développement
économique cde servir et donner le plus
de moyens aux plus riches et par oui
seulement c'est plus riches en
investissant pour donner du travail et
vont à mes yeux la ce qu'il faut ça
marche pas comme ça à la limite
son service est un novice en politique
ce non mais écoutez je marque on n'a
jamais été élu ne qu'il peut avoir des
calculs et mécanique et économétriques
qui n'a absolument aucun sens quand ça
s'applique à un pays qui a une
particularité données et vous savez
qu'il ya eu un million de personnes qui
vivent en france dans des conditions de
misère
inacceptable vous avez ya près de quatre
millions de personnes qui souffrent de
manque de logements quand vous avez ces
paramètres là vous ne supprime pas la pl
comme ça pour hommes étaient pas encore
des emplois aidés ce sont des sas
sociaux qui permettent à des gens de
tenir le coup est-ce que tout nouveau
patron dès demain matin on est quand
même dans une économie très libéral il
fera libéral comme on dit à ce titre là
là je trouve totalement légitimes ses
revendications sociales du pouvoir
d'achat et que c'est une incompréhension
parce que le système actuel qui arrive à
ses limites le système économique
ultralibéral produit trop d'inégalité
dans le monde entier j'ai donné le
chiffre c'est quand même un point sur
les gens qui qui mobilisent 40 1 5 1% de
croissance économique de ceux des
différentes nous et contre l'autre volet
qui est violence oui et démolition de
tout je suis pas d'accord il n'ya pas
compte dans cette revendication des de
droit d'expression
au delà du système parlementaire tels
qu'ils se présentent et qui succès tels
qu'ils se présentent un besoin
d'expression démocratique je suis très
favorable au rhic au référendum d'ici 10
ans ils voyaient ce genre de choses là
je pense qu'il faut absolument associer
de plus en plus la population et qu'on
sera pas au palais bourbon très
tranchées pour tout le monde
en vase clos et qu'on fasse participer
des sites web voilà vous expliquer que
ce que lui martinique elle nie pas pris
le train en marche le train dit gilet
jaune alors que les raisons de descendre
dans la rue
les six régions là sont bien nombreuses
et que et kia et que rien n'a vraiment
changé depuis 2009
nous sommes déçus par ce qui s'est passé
il ya dix ans non je pense que les
martiniquais goldberg tire des
conséquences positives et négatives de
ce qui s'est passé en 2009 dont vous
regardez monsieur macro et lui dire vous
savez monsieur le président tout ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui les grandes
rencontres avec les maires le grand
débat national vous savez ça n'aboutira
à rien on a eu l'excellent cette
expérience ici l'argument je souhaite
vraiment que ça aboutisse à quelque
chose
honnêtement ça c'est au pauvre maman
j'ai un démocrate je suis un autonomiste
républicain je souhaite vraiment je peux
pour monsieur mâcon ne suis pas dans sa
majorité
mais franchement qu'on sorte des
quelques idées quelques grandi j'y crois
pas trop parce que il y à une
technocratie autour de mâcon et je vois
fonctionnel place nationale
je crois pas trop à la sensibilité
émotionnelle liée à la situation du
peuple
je sens pas je sens qu'il ya un espèce
de froideur là et d'incompréhension je
souhaite vraiment qu'on trouve quelques
solutions
mais si monsieur mâcon à commencer par
démolir tout ce qui à solidarité je ne
sais pas s'il reviendra là dessus par
exemple il fallait à revenir sur l' isf
c'est à dire rétablir lisf de telle
sorte que les mails et financier qui
chante céline est sale cc c'est très
très vous vous rendiez que 4 milliards
et ses pin up toutes les associations
sportives et culturelles serais content
d'avoir cette enveloppe non là je vous
dis que la réforme de ces déjà tranché
il a dit non écoutez cieux si vous
ouvrez un grand débat et bois ou quatre
ans chez pour dit non avant mais mieux
commencer débattent vous n'y avez
problème de qui à mon avis ça devait
être au top même s'il dit non à la fin
mais il peut pas dire non au début donc
c'est eux c'est au tour moi c'est un
petit débat c'est un débat qu'on voit
bien que vous êtes très sceptique la
martinique de point de vue social
il y a mon dieu il ya tellement de
sujets qui font mal
la martinique yamal de son transport en
commun la grève perdure toujours au
niveau du réseau mozaik qui est souvent
pris en otage parce que peut-être que le
pro le modèle n'a pas été suffisamment
pensés n'a pas évolué par rapport aux
origines
c'est vraiment une épine saghru cloud en
lapidant dans le pied de la martinique
oui je pense que là mais c'est
extrêmement réducteur c'est ce que ce
que l'on entend et sur le transport
je rappelle quand même que la martinique
était jusqu'à hier
papa longtemps le seul département et
région d'outre-mer où il y avait un haut
niveau d'organisation de transport aimé
césaire pendant très longtemps j'ai tu
tu m'as cft u etc afin de ré
considérable pour pouvoir organiser le
transport qui était privé au départ
et deuxièmement avec et président de la
cacem nous avons réussi à faire
organiser tout lancement davos les
quatre comme très innovant aucune
commune n'avait ce dispositif la boîte
vous n'avez pas salles arrive à sa
personne cayenne et par ben n'en parlons
pas on était même allé plus loin
nous avons collectivement malgré nos
oppositions depuis emile morice camille
darsières claude lise et moi même nous
avons et le plus actuel la collectivité
réaliser le tcsp bon et aujourd'hui nous
avons encore avancé puisque nous avons
demandé à légiférer nous mêmes sur
l'organisation de transports et la
région martinique a créé martin
transport que bastien % c'est la
création de la journée c'était pour
avoir au lieu d'avoir dit cette autorité
organisatrice en avoir une et nous avons
atteint ses objectifs
bon il ya deux choses on a toujours eu
des mouvements dans le transport
toujours toujours toujours mais à ce
point là justement j'y arrive toujours
eu des mouvements
voilà et non même avancer parce que je
vois l'espace eu des avancées très bien
aussi et pour avoir un transport
collectif global parce qu'on a d'autres
mais exemple ça venait à partir je vous
parlais plus aux gens vous refuser de
discuter que les gens moi je recevais
tout le temps les gens jones man a des
capacités temps et à recevoir pendant
les cinq années je vous pose une
question vous avez eu de tels mouvements
pendant cinq ans que nous avons passés à
la collectivité régionale ne payez-vous
- mais il y en avait plein
potentiellement que vous vous éclatez
parce qu'on doit dans un dialogue rompu
à me dire que la direction de la cft une
joue pas son 12e venir soit du tout pas
du tout c'est parce que j'assumais mes
responsabilités et je considère qu'il
fallait absolument avant le dialogue est
le peuple c'est quand même un secteur
sensible et même qu'on ne devait pas
concerner directement la collectivité
régionale
j'invite tout le monde à venir autour de
la table ont trouvé des solutions la
porte est fermée chers amis la porte qui
fait m'ont pas plu à berson icrt unis
transportait ni quoi que ce soit rien du
tout et le soir et français la violence
quand les gens ne se parlent pas la
messe est totalement bloqué c'est ce que
j'ai pas cela parce que n'oubliez pas
que martinique transports qui a la
responsabilité d'organiser le transport
prend des décisions les yeux
unilatéralement
on va fermer cft eu on discute pas avec
vous on remet en cause surtout ce qui
est inadmissible c'est qu'on ne comprend
pas que les et les politiques montrent
beaucoup plus franchement au créneau
concernant cette zone de schoelcher
privée de bus depuis deux mois
ça oui et ça on pourrait discuter je
pense que martin transport qui est
présidé par le paysan la ctm
mais après parfaitement ce qu'elle soit
dix ans et n'a aucune assise
légitimement à cette population qui
n'est pas servi au transport desservi en
transports chercher à cégeps tout ça
anormal et au delà même de prison
s'était mis à le président de la cacem
qui devrait faut pas critiquer condamné
mosaïque parce que l'objectif d'effacer
mosaïque pour mettre un autre outil à
disposition du président a cité m c'est
une tactique politique je pense que là à
la fois le président de martinique
transports qui a été mis sur pied ainsi
que l'horizon a cédé m
mais aussi le président de la cacem
devrait trouver des solutions pour
éviter que ces deux clubs surtout les
élus de martinique de vraiment au
créneau cette espèce cet aspect des
choses
l'économie encore nous avons évoqué avec
jean pierre philibert dans l'émission
sort qu'a dit le jeu pierre philibert le
président de la fedom les aime des fans
chez pas comment votre nom c'est ça les
zones franches d'activités nouvelles
générations
avec pour notre île un volet nautisme et
plaisance on va revenir donc à cette
économique bleus la martinique va
pouvoir enfin rêver en bleu imaginer de
nouvelles filières pour capter la
jeunesse martiniquaise
on a mené une bataille monsieur
philibert vous à nos âmes et nous avons
mené une bataille l'armée nationale et
je suis très content que l'amendement
qui a été proposé à l'assemblée
nationale et la bataille que nous avons
menée et ça nous a permis à main de
maître les cadeaux bible eux il suffit
de reprendre les procès verbaux des
différents débats de mettre l'économie
bleus dans les zones franches nouvelle
génération donc c'est une très bonne
chose
il fallait absolument faire ça on a fait
déjà des avancées puisque vous savez on
avait un problème de fiscalisation des
bateaux qui arrivait un peu en
martinique j'avais demandé un rapport là
dessus des mesures ont été prises
puisque il ya des exonérations qui était
mis sur place qui nous permet d'être
beaucoup plus compétitive pas rose au
pays d'accueil donc c'est une très bonne
chose mais c'est je fais des sites
l'arrivée des zones franches nouvelle
génération des relations qui viennent de
propositions le rôle des délégués et de
propositions venant de moi même en tant
que parlementaire je j'ai dit a misé une
première il n'y a pas de zones franches
sont pas au foie allez il faut des
pauvres parce que si vous faites que
nous sommes forts pour qu'on tourne en
rond nous mêmes sur un marché de 360
milles personnes ça n'a pas de sens
absolument construit des parfums donc
j'attends les dispositifs et on m'a
demandé des progressions là dessus je
ferai des propositions pour qu'on ait
des enfants il faut au moins 3 offrant
de dire qu'on est un échec une échelle
de production beaucoup plus large que la
seule martinique
ça pourrait permettre la matinée nous
relancer sa production interne
concernant l'économie l'octroi de mer
serpent de mer pour propres à chez nous
pour favoriser notre production contesta
bruxelles source de rentrées d'argent
pour les communes
alors quoi en remplacement qu'elle
pourrait être l'idée majeure de serge
letchimy sur la question clé c'est
l'automne mais c'est vraiment ne sert
vraiment là que dans le sens sur
l'octroi de mer c'est à la fois une
source de financement pour les
collectivités locales
c'est une absurdité fiscale économique
dans le sens au plus vous importez je
répète plus vous importez plus les
mairies ont de l'argent
et c'est pas financés comme ça on a vécu
des vols il ya un grave problème et si
vous voulez réduire l'importation vous
diminuez vos recettes
donc les communes n'ont aucun intérêt à
diminuer à vouloir politiquement
diminuer l'importation est solvable
comme équation
c'est une équation stupide mais je viens
de le dire
ouais c'est pas moi qui m'étais mis en
place un peu au gré des mains mais tu
nous regardent avec beaucoup de gros
yeux c'est pas moi qui n'était il ya des
noms savants
donc qu'est-ce qu'il vous devez avoir la
généré politique pour pouvoir changer sa
méthode et je veux la brigade au gosier
je ne peux pas tout faire 2 qu il
faudrait que par état on travaille
dessus et en même temps c'est quand même
un outil écoute et économique
extrêmement important qui permet de
réguler aussi les dynamiques des
plantations pour faciliter la production
locale
par exemple quand vous avez des produits
qui sont importés pour ce qui servent de
base la production locale
eh bien vous avez une taxation
préférentielle et qui est aussi une taxe
ont pris un peu majoritaire majoré pour
les produits importés qui rentrent en
plus grosses avec la production de 4
c'est à la fois un outil développement
économique un outil de défiscalisation
servant des roses de recettes aux
collectivités locales
je pense qu'il faut remplacer ça il faut
donner une dotation spécifique aux
communes clair et net même y compris en
travaillant sur la tva jeudi en
travaillant je ne sais pas que s'il faut
augmenter beaucoup pas peu importe de
telle sorte qu'on a une recette qui soit
et mécaniquement à destination des
collectivités de gaza demandait de
vision fiscale très important mais il
faut garder aussi ça comme outil de
protection et de développement interne
dans notre martinique somme somme
indispensable si on veut pas si on veut
sortir de la dépendance comme diraient
certains
vous êtes sur martinique la première
radio et vous êtes faire face à la
première avec serge chimie on va parler
mais traitement de la santé il nous
reste à peu près 12 minutes d'émission
alors alors serge letchimy deux sujets
reviennent inlassablement le scandale de
la chlordécone avec un volet
indemnisation des victimes toutes les
victimes dites-vous pas seulement les
agriculteurs
ah c'est un sujet très important très
fin d'un monde
je voulais aussi déclaré profiter de
votre émission pour dire notamment à mon
collègue servat puisqu'on a eu un grand
débat national et député de la
guadeloupe je suis pas grand cas quand
on n'est pas lui et moi on n'est même
pas dans une opposition on a du respect
mutuel l'un pour l'autre et que le fait
que ces relais qui me fait une
déclaration contraire à sa position ne
fait pas de deûle et chimie un ennemi
etc c'est pas ça il n'est pas mon ennemi
puisque nous défendons à la limite la
même cause ouais bah il ya une
divergence de vues attend déjà réussi à
différents lieux mais c'est grave c'est
pas si divergents de 800 goûts divergent
de lui bon je vous donne les récifs
il ya une étude qui a été faite en 2018
études santé public français pas moins
c'est une institution et à 92% des
martiniquais nous avons obtenu et 95%
des guadeloupéens sont touchés par la
clau d'école c'est à dire vous en face
de moi ou uniqlo des monologues - money
à quel dosage
on sait pas ce qu'il y'a pas test vous
êtes agriculteur monsieur livory non non
pas du temps vous êtes accusé monsieur
j'ai commencé sous les bons arrêts dans
une question ok bon mot ni parce que
vous savez pertinemment que la
chlordécone
si certaines ou par le contact ça il
faut encore démontré et puis ces housses
aussi et surtout par l'alimentation
vous le savez d'ailleurs ils sont tous
les dalles maximum résiduelles que team
usa passé sur la consommation de ce
qu'on appelle les filles croient les
légumes banques et ça a des conséquences
avérées très puissante puisque depuis 87
79 l'om s a déclaré que c'était
cancérigènes et la même classe en
catégorie 2 vous avez une étude qui a
été faite qui montrent que sur cent
mille personnes
on a 500 cas de personnes qui sont
touchées par le cancer de la prostate en
martinique et 500 personnes touchées par
le cancer de la prostate
on va nous vous envoyons monde qui
touche et en france dans l'hexagone 98
quand vous entendez ces shiffler
et que monsieur mâcon 10 relation de
cause à effet et des isolants pas une
phrase qui est qu'il faut absolument
indiqué il dit clairement que aucun lien
est établi ce n'est pas vrai après leur
accorde pas une petite phrase quand il
dit ça c'est très choquant parce que les
études qui est engagée et pour vérifier
et là et sur la paix la prévalence du
cancer en guadeloupe car oui prostate a
été terminée démontré un lien
les études en martinique ont été
arrêtées en 2014 soit madame buzyn on a
actuellement 1555 cas de cancer chaque
année de plus dont 539 cas de cancer de
la peau ce stade donc la prévalence
existe et deuxièmement le lien de cause
à effet et existe que propose que
propose le gouvernement
le gouvernement propose j'étais présent
dans l'hémicycle des droits qu'eux on
puisse accepter la proposition que les
socialistes ont fait de créer un fonds
pesticides avec de ce fonds pesticides
bien sûr tous ceux qui sont concernés et
nous avions proposé une fait une
proposition de loi avec hélène vainqueur
christophe de 10 m est en fait un texte
un fonds spécifique chlordécone
parce que c'est pas 1000 2000 3000
agriculteurs qui concernait mais 750000
moon matelly guadeloupe martinique
gouacide refusé mais s'était refusée je
le tiens de se servent à 2,1 aquila et
obtenu que font des nominations verrait
le jour conservés lait victimes de la
corde et conan et vous êtes en train de
de me lire une déclaration qui date il y
a deux jours que vous en fait écho oui
moi je suis sur le fait de tromper
servat décide à la place de l'assemblée
nationale qu'il y ait un fonds qui sera
fait saman where did en assemblée à et
ce qui est proposé dans l'assemblée
c'est strictement fonds maladies
professionnelles et accidents de travail
j'insiste beaucoup
réservé aux travailleurs ruraux c'est ça
qui a été annoncé alors maintenant si
ils reviennent là-dessus
et puis que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
ministre qui n'est pas brillant et que
tu n'es pas communiste disent qu'on va
créer un fonds spécifique pour la
chlordécone j'ai pas vu ça j'ai pas lu
ça donc si vous avez cette information
là et que vous êtes certain cette
information dite moi clairement pour
l'histoire je n'ai pas vu ça j'ai vu
simplement un fonds créé des codes
réservées aux agriculteurs aux
travailleurs agricoles comme je demande
à ce qu'il y ait une clarification et
qu'on nous dise comment on va analyser
les gens parce que vous savez que sur
aaa dans l'hexagone sous les 100 mille
personnes qui sont potentiellement
touchées par les pesticides
vous avez dix mille personnes qui font
l'objet d'une analyse plus
spécifiquement vous savez combien en
disent ont été indemnisées 535 on sert à
135 ça reste la v10 et bâle iii
c'est d'inscrire d'autres maladies
professionnelles vous avez une
commission technique
quand monsieur servat de demande à ce
qu'on y voit des dossiers quand je lui
ai dit fais ça peut même être
extrêmement dangereux pour lui je le
répète parce que c'est une commission
avec des médecins qui regardent des
liens de cause à effet c'est pas parce
qu une classe d'école ni indemnisation
il faut absolument aller présenter un
dossier qui peut être contredits et
c'est donc c'est surtout processus
extrêmement compliqué c'est pour ça que
nous avons souhaité qu'il y ait un fonds
chlordécone qui concerne sept cent
cinquante mille personnes et pas de me
libérer les personnes
le temps file serge letchimy on a
tellement de questions à vous poser en
va quand même s'arrêter sur quelque
chose qui concerne la martinerie
concerne la guadeloupe qui concerne la
jeunesse martiniquaise c'est la
formation ce sont des études on va
parler de l'université des antilles
alors justement sur l'université
certains vous accusent d'être d'être dur
d'être derrière en fait de tirer les
ficelles de la situation actuelle de
l'uac et en scission au bord de la
scission entre la guadeloupe et la
martinique
quel type d'accusation par l'ombre et
votre mère on vous accuse de pour
favoriser la scission entre la
guadeloupe et la martinique et vous
répéter sa voûte je vous pose la
question je ne répète pas jouer je dis
ça parce que je pose la question
entendu ça mais franchement si vous
répétez ce que les gens vous disent
comme ça moi j'ai jamais entendu ce type
d'exactions j'ai plutôt entendu que
celle de chimie est un défenseur acharné
de l'ua j'ai gardé lui âgé et
deuxièmement si elle loi qui c'est qu'a
été votée à l'assemblée nationale il ya
deux personnes se sont beaucoup battus
pour que cette loi maintiennent lui
c'est victor lurel et moi même
alors aujourd'hui était très honnêtement
je vous le dis le fait d'avoir répété ça
ça me blesse beaucoup parce que je
n'avais jamais entendu dire ce genre de
choses là donc si vous prenez des petits
points et vous revenez
maintenant il y à une situation actuelle
je suis en guadeloupe avec plusieurs
élus aide parlementaire il ya un mois
invité dans une ligne au travail où j'ai
clairement indiqué le contraire c'est
bizarre je vous comprends pas maintenant
il ya une tension entre et deux
personnes le président de l'ua et la
présidente de la vice président du pôle
martin écoles martinique
bon je considère c'était à moi de me
mêler de ce genre le conflit là et qu'il
faut tout faire pour maintenir alors
justement si on maintient pas lui mais
ce sera la fin alors les personnes qui
vous renseigne dites-leur franchement de
cesser d'être malhonnête qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette initiative entre
ary chalus ce et le président de la ctm
qui ont décidé de d'arabes d'approcher
la guyane pour rushydro forme est lui
âgé ou voir même d'étendre à l'arrêt
leur poser la question pour quelle
raison quand il était là ils n'ont rien
fait pour boire mais tenez un gain
latchimy il nous reste encore quatre
minutes d'émission
vous avez demandé de réfléchir sur
l'aérien sur nos aéroports sur nos
dessertes l'aérien son développement
pour booster notre économie
puis bah dames la norvégienne au kit
trop fait mal bien entendu mais c'est en
commencement on savait les flux aériens
sur son son ça marche bien un moment ça
marche moins bien
à d'autres moments je le regrette parce
qu'elle car il n'aura qu'à me avait fait
un travail exceptionnel en faisant le
lien avec les états unis notamment pour
la croisière si norvégienne part il faut
se poser la question
je n'ai pas de détails que vous pourriez
avoir sur les raisons du départ de nova
général je le regrette parce que c'est
difficile de remplir les avions départ
pour est à pitre départ fort hors de
france soit que c'est difficile de
demander aux antillais de dalé par
exemple à new york au mois de juin
dynamique touristique parce qu'il est
nos vielles n'est pas venu que pour
faire venir les martiniquais de relever
à miami aux new york
c'était aussi pour faire des fleuves
arrivée par flux et des touristes qui
prennent la croisière ici kippen les
bateaux de croisière donc c'est
peut-être ça où il ya une faille et je
pense qu'il faut poser la question aux
personnes qui sont ils sont responsables
de ça pour quelles raisons l'évolution
même du tourisme de croisière ne pm
panneaux viennent de rester il y à
quelques événements récents et qui ont
pu déstabiliser un petit peu les bateaux
de croisière mais je pense qu'on peut
rétablir la confiance
que devient cette mission de l'aérien ça
avance très bien
on a terminé nos douze propositions sont
là des propositions extrêmement clair
sous des possibilités de connexion entre
la l'amérique du sud
des possibilités aussi l'organisation
sur le bassin caraïbe et des connexions
plus facile mais parce qu'on est très
enclavée on peut parler en jamaïque
facilement la question des as
saisonnalité des prix et à des billets
d'avion sur très très cher à certains
moments moins cher à d'autres ça c'est
pas acceptable pour les familles les
problèmes du double contrôle et à la
france parfois martinique et en arrivant
à paris
sartre et ainsi aborder des problèmes de
formation ça je chante quand même je
forge au plafond une centre de formation
dans la caraïbe de l'aérien pour les
pilotes de ligne et si que les
mécaniciens etc
il ya douze propositions
la loi sous le transport la mobilité va
arriver à l'insémination à métaux il ya
des propositions que je formule qui sont
d'ordre législatif et à des provisions
que je forme et qui sont peu qu'ils sont
d'ordre technique mais a priori ces deux
conventions ont été retenus une dernière
question puisque nous arrivons quasiment
tire de cette émission avec 20,9
alors c'est cela qui me faut-il
supprimer les 40% le président de la
république semble dire que c'est la
principale cause de la vie chère martine
paris se trompent lourdement je pense
qu'il faut vraiment ouvrir le débat sur
les 40 % puisque s'il faut l'ouvrir
j'ai d'ailleurs été de favorables avec
plusieurs hypothèses possibles
je pense qu'il faut pas comme pour
l'abattement fiscal venir gripper bédié
on modifie tout il n'a pas vous avez
fait une petit roadster il n'a pas
supprimé l'abattement
il a réuni lundi la porte de
l'abattement faut pas faire de procès
d'intention comme ça à mâcon j'étais
construction et n'ont rien battu là
dessus parce que je considère que c'est
une mauvaise chose pour le pays mais
pour les quarts en poussant je suis
contre la suppression des 40%
je suis par contre favorable à ce qu'on
ouvre une discussion pour voir est ce
qu'une part de ces grains poussant à
l'initiative de la personne qui
bénéficient des gares imposant durée
investir localement en finançant ce
qu'on appelle des fonds de venir
entendre sans peut comprendre ça à paris
tellement n'a envie de suivre une
feuille de route
je vous donne mon opinion je ne suis pas
de la tête de qui que ce soit à paris
vous seriez paris est un petit peu ils
sont sourds à certains moments ils
comprennent pas bien les réalités
j'ai entendu tellement de bêtises à
l'assemblée nationale y compris que si
on avait mis l'abattement fiscal en
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane 1
dans les années 60 c'était pour
apprendre aux antillais à payer l'impôt
on a quelques mépris et quand on roule
issa en pleine assemblée j'ai réagi
assez viril à moins bien entendu mais
vous entendu tout et n'importe quoi le
jeu je pense que c'est une encore une
réflexion et économiques techniques
d'économie et c'est pas un raisonnement
sociale je pense donner la possibilité
aux martiniquais de réinvestir leurs 40
% 10 % dans le btp ou dans la mutation
énergétique
ça peut être quelque chose de très bien
mais il faut pas amputer nitouche aux
40% j'ai pas favorable
merci d'avoir été avec nos serge et
e-mails pays député de la martinique
président du parti progressiste
martiniquais
merci d'avoir été avec nous c'était face
à la première avec al ahly vori au micro
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine et
puis on espère que vous reviendrez très
bien
où s'arrêtera bientôt un bon dimanche
face à la première
[Musique]
et